et en septembre 2009 lors d'une
manifestation sur la réforme des
retraites
vous avez interpellé sur les violences
policières en disant je cite c'est des
barbares soyez prudent il ne s'arrête
plus maintenant sur les violences
policières
jean luc mélenchon est ce que pensent et
qui a une haine anti-flic en france et
est ce que vous comprenez les gens qui
disent que vous attisez parfois cette
haine anti-flic par vos sorties dans les
manifestations ou voilà par voilà des
phrases comme celle ci qu'est ce que
vous dites à ça parce que bell jeudi
je vais vous répondre si la phrase que
vous citez si une phrase volé je suis en
train de parler avec un gars et cas les
cheveux blancs on blague et j'ai lu dié
voulait qu'on leur voix non si vous
voulez les ailes et je blague avec loin
parce qu'avant on avait connu
d'enseignement professionnel c'est pas
ça qui les a intéressés les voleurs dit
malachor v derrière vous a dénoncé un
boss c'est des barbares soyez prouver je
lui dis court pas de vent sont des
barbares
ouais alors hurlements il ya dix
barbares comment barbara tous les toutes
les semaines il y avait un mot donc
alerté le mot barbare
le président chirac est décédé donc ça
s'est arrêté au bout de deux jours
l'épisode barbare mais je vais vous dire
maintenant et avec le recul
oui ce sont des barbares ceux qui on
tirait sur ined redouane à marseille au
quatrième étage et l'ont tué oui ce sont
des barbares ce qui de sang froid ont
tiré en pleine figure de 32 personnes
qui ont perdu leur oeil et personnes
autour n'a rien vu oui ce sont des
barbares
ceux qui pratiquent l'omerta est dit je
n'ai rien vu ce sont des barbares
quand il se comporte comme il se
comporte de cette manière là et quand
ils ont un syndicat factieux comme y en
a plusieurs qui sont capables d'aller
menacer des juges qui menace des avocats
qui menace les chefs de partis
politiques pour que tout le monde se
taise
et bien moi je n'ai pas peur et je suis
content d'avoir dit la vérité mais je la
vérité est que ce type de peau l'islam
n'en voulons par type de police là mais
jean-luc mélenchon vous voulez vous
aller vous représentez en 2022 à quoi
alors que dix ans c'est sûr et je suis
aimé président comment vous pouvez
parler comme ça de la police et ça sinon
vous voyez pas
ce terrible je ne parle pas de la police
mais les gens le prennent comme ça mais
je ne suis pas responsable aussi je vois
sur responsable on peut plus parler non
mais ça va pas demander comme ça non
mais monsieur là tu peux rien moi j'ai
été au contraire
parmi ceux qui s'avançait pour dire ça
suffit
c'est pas ça qu'on veut voir dans ce
pays c'est pas sept types de police j'ai
eu combien d'amis qui étaient des
syndicalistes policiers ils sont plus là
maintenant ils sont à la retraite mais
c'étaient des amis il avait une vision
de la police républicaine
moi je suis pour le gardien de la paix
pas pour les forces de l'ordre qui
maintient que je ne sais quoi
armés jusqu'aux dents dans les
manifestations je suis pour qu'il ne
soit plus armé mais dans les
manifestations simulation et j'en ai
assez de la portée générale de la police
nationale
jean lui me posais policier jean luc
bernard dont je me suis dit je vais tout
d'abord je suis comme karim je tiens à
le dire vous êtes aux républicains il
faut arrêter de dire n'importe quoi
je remercie mes 10 de la demande en mai
après il ya d'autres dé vous avez avec
vous si beaucoup de choses mais j'aime
pas connu qu'on catalogue les gens ne le
mérite pas mais quand vous dites ça par
exemple ces débats mais peut-être que
certains jeunes des barbares encore une
fois mais le policier d'accord qui
justement est là pour le pôle maintien
de l'ordre mais vous avez vu une fois
les situations dans lesquelles ils sont
bien sûr et bien sûr que ça dérape
il va y mettant des mais c'est mais il
faut se mettre à leur place un certain
moment d'autres dire ce sens que des
barbares je suis désolé c'est ça c'est
pas je sais c'est pas gentil et c'est
pas vrai et c'est pas vaincu on est
d'accord
connaissent ils me l'ont noté que la
forêt mais mais mais des fois c'est le
big air et vous avez j'ai été d'abord
validée sociaux je vous garantis sur le
truc moi je suis parti à deux points
je vous dis la vérité je me suis dit à
certains moments si je m'entoure mais
alors qu'est ce que vous proposez
attendez si je vais d'abord bien sûr la
force est trop fort moi je n'ai pas fait
de déclaration pour dire c'est des
barbares je parle à quelqu'un d'autre
dans la rue mais je ne vois pas
quelqu'un qui me filme et il le pas sur
toutes les chaînes pour dire oh mon dieu
mélenchon a dit barbare mais alors à la
maison aussi je vais te surveiller
qu'est ce que c'est si ça va non non non
mais cyril vous avez vous-même cyril
hanouna vous avez vous même enchaîné en
disant vous n'avez pas le droit de dire
mais je n'ai jamais dit tout la police
des barbares
si je suis à l'époque donc fort préciser
votre oui oui oui ma position je suis
pour une police républicaine
je suis pour qu'on rétablisse le code de
déontologie de 1986 qui a été abrogée
par monsieur valls je suis pour que les
policiers fautifs soient punis pour que
les autres ne soient pas salies par ces
pratiques professionnelles
je suis pour que l'inspection générale
de la police nationale ne soit pas faite
que par des policiers oui mais par des
gens qui sont aussi des sociologues des
avocats des gens qui connaissent la vie
voilà et ensuite je suis pour que on
désarme les policiers dans les manifs
ils n'ont pas besoin de cet armement
lourd qui est dangereux c'est une des
choses a des pistes mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai désarmement désarmez m'a dit
qu'il va se faire massacrer des civils
désarmés et que vous ne mettez pas trois
fois plus chers amis vous êtes comme moi
quand il ya quand y'a personne on fait
des cortèges a marché du vieux-port et
on monte là bas mais ça vous arrive et
vanilla il n'y a pas un policier